one of the biggest stories in gaming
this week is of course gaming youtube
com and we're here alive on the YouTube
stage here I'm Chris waters from
GameSpot and talking with some game
developers who also have a really big
story this week the Kickstarter success
of divinity original sin 2 and joining
me on the stage sweat and thomas from
Larian you guys congratulations first
off on your game funding within like 12
hours thank you very much christenings
very exciting no doubt and as people
continue to be drawn to the kickstarter
and sort of see what what you guys are
taken on here with divinity original sin
to how does it feel to be like launching
such an ambitious project i would say
that it's incredibly exciting but we're
so tired because campaign has been going
so fast that we don't have time to
realize what's going on you're tired
already i mean you guys still have a lot
of development to go here yeah well we
had quite a bit of vicious and coming
over here and all over hardware i broke
down or Kickstarter page was lost so we
had to scramble to get everything ready
in time well you've got the game
playable here on the show for the
kickstarter is just a success so i'd say
you're doing okay yeah we're happy i'm
not complaining alright so we're gonna
actually take a look at the game in
action you guys are going to load it up
and we're gonna see one of the the key
features here for original sin to
multiplayer in action yeah so we're
going to be playing actually on the same
pc we're using controllers so this is a
pre-alpha version of the game of course
since we still have many months of
development ago but we're running it on
the divinity original sin Enhanced
Edition engine so that means that we can
already play from the get-go and it also
allows us to to explore many many many
new things in the RPG country now
enhanced edition is the version of
divinity original sin that's currently
out now on steam is that correct no
actually current version is original
Cindy enhanced edition is coming this
October for ps4 and xbox one day so
enhanced edition is just the console no
it will also come to everybody who has
it on PC gets it for free and
interjected too early
yeah and so what this one is going to be
coming like end of 2016 most likely it's
actually going to already shift into
2017 with all the stuff that we're
adding on top of it says resolve the
Kickstarter so we've got multiplayer and
let's get into what you guys are trying
to do here because it's not it is
cooperative like your adventuring
together but it's not as simple we sort
of read the same dialogue we take on the
same quest we are just twice as powerful
no absolutely not so it takes some time
to explain so let me explain Thomas
maybe you best join in tonight that way
I'm going to shift to split screen mode
so I'm going to let almost join in and
so there he is so he's on the other side
of the world he's controlling my dwarf
and I'm going to assign control of my
fief to him also so he's now controlling
a thief and dwarf and I'm in the
meantime being addressed by a dwarf that
noticed me arrived here on the beach and
she's asking me aren't you supposed to
be in jail because we're escaped
prisoners and it's actually an important
thing because this is my main character
the one that I created that character
creation Gwyn Welford aha he's a
noblewoman she comes from this island
where we crash-landed and so everybody
is going to recognize her but if our
friends at Thomas is going to talk to
somebody then and he's going to get the
different dialogue course in original
sin too it's all about your origin
stories what your race is who you are
what you are how it defines your life
your options in life and that's the main
theme of the game so i'll show you a
couple examples of that yeah so if
you're coming up to a checkpoint you
might want him the dwarf to roll up and
say hey do the dudes are talking if you
know you're gonna get recognized so
that's a so let me give you an example
of that so for instance over here I have
ax men here it's a statue if I click on
it I recognize it i was afraid of it as
a kid now if i'm going to take my ELF
here because you can play as multiple
races in or Johnson to go so this is the
wood elf well if she's going to talk to
the ax men then she says she's not from
around here so she says he's pretty
impressive now we stole my friend human
for a human and so if Thomas is going to
talk to him what he says is like this
was as though it was a butcher he killed
many many doors so we all have different
perspectives on the events that are
going on in the game and that creates
for quite some interesting moments
absolutely and also the
telling urge to cycle through and like
really play as all your characters as
part of the gameplay actually which
party member you're going to be a pic to
solve certain situation is going to have
a very big impact on you and the thing
is that you can play with up to four
players you can play cooperatively but
you can also play competitively and it's
not only peer competitively as in PvP
but you also get to play competitively
as a narrative manner so how that works
I have to show you because that's that
hasn't been done before yeah when you
think of when I think of competitive and
I look at it you know game like divinity
original sin too I think oh well maybe
they're just like competing to who gets
the most wolf pelts in a fight against
wolves and then they go back and like
whoever wins gets a better reward oh
that's not that you guys are on a whole
different level here absolutely blech
city and ambition and it's been
fascinating all right so let me show you
a very small example of that so we are
greeted by the guards here we're not
they have problems with Dwarfs on the
inside the village and so he recognizes
me says Gwyn aren't you supposed to be
in jail and so I'm gonna lie i'm going
to say that I've been given clemency by
Bishop Alexander himself and so he
believes me and so I can ask for my
fellow travelers to be allowed to go go
into town now what I could / try
persuasion event on him where I'm not
going to do that instead i'm going to
say you know what they can sort it out
themselves and what happens then is that
the guards block the other guys and I
can just dash off inside of the village
and go and have fun and see my old
friends and relatives and so forth so
because you got to that conversation you
were able to kind of slam the door a
little bit and now the other people in
your party have a different challenge
they haven't overcome to get to where
you're exactly so for instance I am I
elf over here so she can try to convince
him and you see that she has different
dialogue options the entire dialogue is
different because that's who she is and
the game recognize this isn't health
this is how this guy's gonna talk to an
elf and so when you're creating your
character you get these little tags that
you see there like charmer or elf elf
obviously because of my race color
because of who I am what I picked in
character creation so she picks a
scholar option I know this is the good
option here he's also going to allow me
me and now the dwarf however is going to
be a different story so Thomas is going
to try to politely ask to be let in you
already see that he's talking the very
racist manner to to Thomas and so he
says I have a row
living over here he says no that's not
going to work you are not going in so
Thomas has a little bit of a temper so
he's going to insult him and so the
guard just tells him to dash off and
he's not going to enter so what I'm
going to do now is I'm going to quickly
take control of Thomas's sweep for
presentation purposes and then just go
to Hudson here as soon as my feet he has
a very dark past and so if he talks to
the dwarf over here he gets a
conversation and which he can ask is
there another way into the city and so
this man is not going to tell it to me
unless I give him some gold but I don't
have any gold however if Thomas goes and
talk to him what Thomas is going to see
is that as he goes through the dialogue
that he's going to have the option of
actually convincing the guy to tell him
is there another way into the city and
because it's a dwarf to dwarf
conversation and so he's going to be
able to go in and so we're gonna split
up over here I'm just going to go
convince the guards that I can actually
that he allows my fief to enter also so
let me do that and since it's a racist
as an environment if i say i'm a human
just like you he says okay that's fine
there all right yeah you can you can go
in so let's try out I have to just I
can't help but look at this in a be
amazed at the complexity of just a small
interaction but be thinking you guys
have like maybe quadrupled your workload
want more than that we have more than
that more origin stories well the thing
is we're building it on top of the
announced edition which is already very
very powerful yeah and so it gives us
the entire RPG framework to build
something really unique on top and we
already have to split screen from the
Enhanced Edition we already had the
co-operative mode so going from there to
put competitive in was like a logical
next step because it allows I'll let me
show you a couple of examples allows us
to do a great many things all right
let's so let me take control of win here
I need to show you one
extra thing here so in wild Tomas will
just be hanging out in a bush over there
he's trying to get in through the other
way but he has to deal with those assets
Lux over there that they're bothering
him and he's going to be using a sword
skill but I don't think you have a
source go I don't think so no do you
know you'll have to go and get your blob
stones because i forgot to take him
that's where i'll go back alright so we
have a new set of skills which are
called sword skills and to be able to
cast them you need a source stone you
know what to us i can actually get you
one hold on can you yeah i'm gonna kill
a kill somebody and then be great
alright so there's many ways of getting
its cooperative to all right yeah for
sure so this man over here unfortunately
I'm going to have to kill him so that I
can access his source where is he it's
gonna go in his chair man doesn't know
what's gonna have I'm gonna jump the man
in his sorry Jerry if I Mumford of his
own home don't hear you know I have a
hard time seeing because I have a lot of
light in my yeah it's very bright yeah
all right there you go so that killed
him and what happens is that his ghost
is going to appear now spirit whispering
is a new talent that we have and I can
basically talk to him and as I sought to
him I can talk to I well in this case i
can only steal his soul so if i do that
i take his astral energy and what I've
done now is I charge what's called the
bloodstone I'm gonna send this
bloodstone to manga in the dwarf because
he needs it to survive those assets Lux
and in the meantime I'm going to try to
sort out their [ __ ] so the problem in
this town is the reason why there's so
much insurgency is the mayor has been
poisoned and this was the healer taken
care of her and so I was supposed to go
and figure out who it anymore I mean so
but I still would like to know who it is
and so this is a shortcut through a very
long quest but what I'm going to do here
is I'm going to be not very nice and I'm
going to
hold on it yeah I'm going to starve a
little bit of fire just a little bit and
that should be the end of it and there's
an over go to the peers because it's a
it's a mechanic anybody that you kill a
spiritual appeared and all the spirits
you can question them you can talk to
them and so you can actually gain altar
inside the only problem I have right now
is I'm entering the dark side of the
source and so I'm going to lose a lot of
Pharma and I'm gonna have to deal with
that yeah I was wondering no but there's
got to be some balance here otherwise
you're just running around harvesting
villagers willy-nilly to power yourself
you're going to be a very heavy price to
pay for what I'm doing but that's fine
because it's fun to play dark and so so
i just also stole her source know that I
know who she was poisoned by I said I
couldn't go and act on that how's it
going Tomas right now i'm gonna use one
of these news source kills the meteor
shower actually to kill all these slugs
because there is a pretty big problem
for me we know that's pretty powerful
yeah so it's trying to until you see
that those little poison gases the
clouds that are coming out of there
because these guys beat boise when I to
the fire and so it creates a gas plus
looks like you didn't quite get them all
or was our Hill the other one burned up
they're all dead here I need to get over
this fire surface down but I can use my
thanks go retreat and jump over it there
we go okay well done so in the meantime
I'm going to go to my answer to
ancestral house and go talk to my
brother who recognize me obviously now
you need to realize I didn't have to
have twin well further than my party it
could have been somebody else and then I
wouldn't see all of these dialogue
options appear I wouldn't have the angle
of being from this town and that's it's
going to go for all of the characters
actually so you have all these origin
stories that are in there and it makes
for a very interesting RPG gameplay
there are more origin stories that you
can have in a single party yeah so
you're not gonna you know even though
you're probably going to when you're
creating your character and spreading it
around well I mean it's a we're gonna
see it in example so if I were playing
single player that work would be in my
party and then the option that's about
the affair wouldn't happen
the messenger that just went to Thomas
and he says excuse me my employer would
like to give you a proposal so as he
hands or receives a note can you read
the note to Thomas sure we open in my
inventory all right let's try that so
what is the note it's an assassination
request against me so this is one an
example of one of those competitive
quests so he now has a secret which I
don't know if I would be playing in
multiplayer obviously we're playing in
split screen so I see what he mean yeah
you see the opportunity later headed
right he's probably assuring you know I
would efforts he might not be paying
attention though so that's good form he
might be absorbed in his own thing yeah
yeah key so you guys might have rigged a
Beemer so cardboard in the middle of the
screen there's a well there's a lot of
things that you can do to one another
this way I mean I I don't know how much
time we have to otherwise if I get a few
more minutes we have a few more minutes
a few more minutes then I'll show you
something differently that's what I what
I could do was I was I could have
dropped it eh I could have taken
opposing portion combine it with a red
tie and it would have looked like a
healing potion I could have put it up
with pickpocketing in his backpack and
then if he would have drunk it he would
have been poisoned he would have it
poison but they could have done that to
me of course a preliminary hey I know
you you got an offer let me just let
help you refuse that off huh so let me
show you a couple of other new things at
almost if you can make it to the lone
wolves then I'm in the meantime going to
demonstrate skilled craft think now I'm
apologized that I have to squint like
this but oh that's fine and you guys I
think what's you know you guys are in
totally different places well not
totally yeah we're you're in similar
region may be evil like others you're
doing totally different things in your
cooperative endeavor and so you're
you're having this adventure that's like
are laying out so far apart but you're
still in the same world you can team up
together and like share resources and
you could be playing it rolling together
if you had managed that sort of entry to
the town a different way but now you're
playing it this way in both ways are
equally viable yeah so you can
seamlessly switch between cooperative
and competitive and that's a lot of fun
so the thing I'm going to do is show you
something else that's new this is
skilled crafting so for instance if i
combine a let's say a summon spider
skill book with a mute skill so that's
this can you guess what's going to
happen
I if this slider will not be able to
talk when you somehow okay almost i'm
gonna get a ninja spider so it's gonna
be a stealth spider so later that sounds
horrifying is X are spiders already
ninjas in if you want yeah so if I
summon it now it's going to be able to
let me just do that here if I summon
that ninja spider it will be able to
summer I hide itself and then by
somebody from behind in combat which is
pretty cool or you know if a certain
dwarf comes up to you with his axe some
cheese and takes a might happen alright
Thomas can you go behind you don't have
to peep sorry let me just give him the
beep also all right and then I need to
see my stairs here there's so much light
okay there you go now the dwarf is just
hanging out where the dwarf was but he's
Thomas now controlling the thief in the
same area that you are is because we're
in the same area so we're switching to
hobo if you switch out of split-screen
into the doctor yeah so because that
we're close to one another so the camera
zooms out and if we're too far from each
other then what happens is that it goes
back to split screen so this is all
present in the Enhanced Edition and will
be playable for players very soon as
nice a lot of fun to do that so I want I
want to show you one last thing it's
gonna take one minute but it's very cool
alright we weren't even really cool one
who saves it out you want to see this
alright so what he's going to do now is
he's going to get into an ambush by some
old friends of them he has different
motivations than me here because he is
actually an assassin he didn't tell any
of us he has personal motivation from
beasts like any character and he got
himself into a fight with old colleagues
of them which i didn't know about so I
can of course go and help him
so let's have a look and see that he's
engaged in combat but you're not
engaging that's also new now you are
what i can do is i can basically decide
if i'm going to go into combat or not or
i can actually backstab him so now we're
doing pvp combat and we're going to be
fighting with one another and then we
can make up if we want to like an old
good relationship and make a lot of fun
so you guys if you destroy the other
antagonists in the battle can you call
off the fight or do you have just one of
you have to defeat the other and then
the fight ends did you like no we can
always go so we can I can just go and
make peace for him so like so it's going
to be my turn I can make these with him
so where is it hello okay so for
instance I just have to find them back
because I the hard time seeing all right
there is so I can just say make these
and now we're going to be back on the
air on the same side wow just like that
so it's all very fluid you join in and
obviously most people will be playing it
if they play the multiplayer they are
played cooperatively from time to time
they'll just like say I this is really
interesting for me I want to do this
some guys will try to really compete
with each other as possible and then
others will obviously playing single
player and then all of that work that
we're doing from the competitive and the
cooperative translates into a very rich
single player experience because there's
so many options on every single
situation at the encounter is a lot of
fun so many options indeed and you guys
I gotta commend you for your ambition
with this it looks so so exciting
obviously a lot of people excited about
on Kickstarter well a lot of fans of
original sin the gamespot staff included
congratulations you guys and so you are
looking to do some alpha release some
early access stuff at in the coming
everybody who backs is on Kickstarter
gets the automatically elf and the
bettas and that's not gonna be this year
that's going to be somewhere next year
alright well thank you guys so much for
coming on and showing off unity original
sin to all right thank you very much
Chris thank you guys for more on
divinity original sin to as development
continues go to gaming youtube.com slash
gamespot click that little star follow
us and i'll keep you updated we'll be
back with a discussion of the top five
games of the year so far in just a
minute stick with us